oh hi
i was just reading about black holes and
lost track of time if you want to be
transported the same way
i was click on the link below to get our
what if 100 book
now let's start today's episode
[Music]
you chew it you stretch it
you blow it and to be honest
sometimes you stick it on things but
what happens to your body when you
swallow
chewing gum and not just once
but all the time
if you always swallow your gum could it
plug up your body and
is it true it could kill you
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you always swallowed your chewing gum
it's minty fruity and
mmm delicious we love it so much that
globally it's a 29 billion dollar
industry that's
expected to double by the year 2025.
chewing gum might even help your health
a study from swinburne university said
that
chewing gum can help reduce stress
levels
and a 2002 study showed that chewing
a piece of sugar-free gum could improve
your short-term memory
but it also contains many ingredients
used in things like
caulking white glue and plastic bags
so is it safe to swallow gum
well first let's start by saying that
gum
does not stay in your stomach for seven
years
you knew that right a healthy body can
expel a piece of gum in
a few days so swallowing a piece of gum
from time to time
isn't going to kill you but if you
always
choose to gobble down your gum it could
be another story
the problem is gum doesn't break down
like other food
gum like some seeds and corn
can turn into indigestible masses called
beesores they can accumulate in your
digestive tract
and even cause a blockage it's because
gum is a kind of rubber originally made
of
chickel a sap from the sapodilla tree in
central america
it was synthesized in a laboratory after
world war ii
do you still want to try this seriously
alrighty then you've been swallowing
several pieces of gum each day for a few
days
and they're building up in your
digestive system
if foods fluids gastric acids and
gas build up behind the blockage
it could create pressure
[Music]
you would probably experience bloating
diarrhea vomiting and constipation among
other things and pain
you would definitely feel pain you
should
probably pack a few things and seek
treatment at the closest hospital
if it's a partial blockage then you're
lucky
it's easier to treat the problem you'll
likely get
intravenous fluids to rehydrate your
body
a catheter into your bladder to drain
out your urine and
a tube into your stomach to relieve
pressure
swelling and vomiting but if you have
a complete blockage it could tear you
apart
your intestines could rupture leaking
harmful bacteria
into your abdominal cavity that
could kill you even if your stomach or
intestines
don't rupture a blockage can
prevent blood from getting to other
parts of your intestines
that can cause infection tissue death
sepsis and multiple organ failures
and that could kill you too just in case
you're wondering
in both cases you might need to go under
the knife and
that would be no fun so
yeah it's a terrible idea to keep
swallowing your chewing gum
now if you have a taste for chewy stuff
what would happen if you only ate
raw meat
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]